jimmy jam and terry lewis join us now
good morning you guys it's so exciting
to have you here
so nice to see icons isn't it yes icons
and legends
it's so nice is that the same thing no i
no
no no but i i do want to say you had the
idea to have this album 35 years ago so
jimmy i want to know what took you guys
so long to actually produce your own
album
well it actually started back 35 years
ago because we were producing an album
called control which is 35 years old
and janet actually stole one of our
songs from our album which
turned into what have you done for me
lately so it launched her career it
ended ours at least on the artist side
of things
um and it's time for we appreciate it to
actually get there yeah so
that's what's taking so long terry why
is now the right time for this album
well it couldn't be a better time uh we
went through a couple years of covet
and it gave us time to settle down and
get all the artists
and friends together and make music and
that's what we did
all right i'm originally from i'm
originally from minneapolis are we gonna
hear any minneapolis sound
on this album we actually reunited
morris day along with jerome benton
which is which is actually terry's
brother jerome is terry's brother that's
right what's up bro and then for the
band
we used the roots so it's a great
collaboration i think you guys will
really enjoy it
and and also the sounds of blackness and
the sounds of blackness are also on
there from minneapolis
50 years they're celebrating this year
so yeah
jimmy i've already heard it i love it
terry hi it's good to see you too
you know that janet jackson song that's
the way love goes
that was my divorce song i remember that
song that was the one i'm not kidding
that got me through i remember being on
the dance floor dancing by myself we all
have that song
we all have a song like that but listen
you've worked with mariah on this album
mary j blige i love the spinning song
no janet this time how did you decide
who you were going to work with what was
the process
we put a wish list together of people
who we love to work with and obviously
a lot of people on the wish list uh we
are doing a volume two by the way that's
why we're calling the album volume one
so there still is a volume two uh and a
volume three and
hopefully a whole bunch of them that
we'll do but at this point in our
careers we're
having so much fun and we basically put
our wish list together and a bunch of
people were nice enough to say yes
no nobody's gonna say no to you too
terry i'm fascinated by the
collaboration of you and jimmy together
because you guys met as teenagers you
were in the outward bound program
the two of you upward bound upward bound
that's right upward bound
and that you discovered you had two
different tastes in music what was it
you were you and he was what was that
upward bound i'm the
i'm the funky guy he's the pretty guy
he's a pretty boy so thank you terry but
thank you but
but at some point we figured how to mesh
it together i guess the first song was
uh just be good to me by the sos band
so um it was a little bit difficult at
first because i would always put my
funky bass part on his
pretty cords and it kind of just didn't
go and then he said no
not that you do the vice versa but we
figured it out after a while i like
funky boy and pretty boy
we got a pretty boy here too actually
anthony's on vacation
go ahead pretty boy tony go ahead all
right look
guys tonight culpa here most people some
people write
one hit uh maybe two you've got hits in
three decades and i'm curious how you
kept
up that longevity that consistency and
how you actually start where does a song
begin for you
well actually it's four decades but
who's counting
pretty boy but no it's really
for us it's really the inspiration the
artist is the inspiration we tailor make
the songs for each artist we try to not
ever do the same thing for the same
you know for different people right so
we want that suit to fit perfectly for
that artist
exactly the way that they want it the
color the fit and the whole thing
and that's really been i think this not
the secret to our longevity
the other thing i'll say is we actually
planned on having a long career
when we did our very first interview
somebody said to us you guys are the
hottest producers and we said we don't
want to be the hottest producers
we want to just be warm for a long time
so that's what we're trying to still do
you know you've had 41 hits in the top
10 on the billboard charts is there a
particular song or album you're really
proud of
well we got to always say go back to our
minneapolis roots and say probably the
the kind of time capsule song i guess if
we were going to put something in a time
capsule and open it 100 years later
that really explains jamming lewis uh it
would be the song optimistic by the
sounds of blackness
probably our favorite song that we've
ever been associated with easily
that's a good one i i do have to ask
because you know i moved from
minneapolis i'm out in los angeles you
guys moved from minneapolis out to los
angeles are you more minneapolis or los
angeles and how much did minneapolis
hate you when you left
i don't think we ever got any hate we
love minneapolis
it's still home you know a home is where
the people you love live
in minneapolis is that so you know we're
in l.a but we love minneapolis and we
love you guys and after all these years
you clearly still love what you do
why do you love what you do so much
because it's still i look at rhythm
nation which
by the way still holds up today right it
still holds up today
yeah which is kind of bittersweet it's
because it's
you know you're happy that music holds
up but then
the messages that are on that album we
thought would be eradicated we wouldn't
be talking about racism and all of these
things still now today so
that's kind of too bad but listen we
wake up every day with a song in our
head
not necessarily a good one but at least
there's an idea in our heads every day
and the cool thing for me and and i
think for terry is that we get to work
together
we've known each other for 40 plus years
now um
and we love working together and there's
nothing else that we really know how to
do well
so i think we're just going to continue
with this
to learn anything new who decided on the
look the sunglasses and the black hat
because they are definitely iconic it's
early in l.a
but it's definitely a look you always
know when you see them exactly who it is
who decided on that look terry
well this look actually comes from a lot
from me from my family
because uh in my family all the men wore
hats
and suits and it's kind of the look that
i adopted over the years if
you look at little kid pictures of me
and pretty boy said i like that look i'm
gonna do it too also you don't have to
make any excuses
that's right also come on in pretty boy
jimmy
guys congrats the album's very very very
i love it it's awesome i can't wait for
number two
oh and three and four and five thank you
guys so much for being with us we
appreciate it their full album jam
and lewis volume one will be released
mark your calendar
this friday